I'll tell you what, hijab is a big draw
here amongst the community, amongst
people in general
and he would be prepared for this bout
through his
team, through the people who support
him.
He's come a long, long way.
I've personally seen Muhammad hijab
transform himself as a person,
someone from speaker corner giving
lectures, giving daer
to appearing on Piers Morgan, not once
but twice.
And I tell you what,
I'm really excited to see him fight
again. I'm so happy to see Muhammad
Hijab in the cage,
you know, testing his metal in this game
cuz martial arts is a tough game and so
far he's come to it like water.
>> Yeah, I'm very excited to see him as
well. I was in the house last time
around looking forward his second fight.
>> He's definitely a fan favorite.
fighting out the blue corner represent
JJson.
>> So Hijab's opponent JJ Bumpstead
from Silverbacks MMA
I hope your last time. I said
>> the other guy
Heat. Heat.
This is our main event
fighting down the red corner and JJ
fighting down the blue corner. Pro
heavyweight
fighters.
So, battle of the heavyweights there.
Bumstead has a
professional record of 1 and0 MMA.
Likewise, does Muhammad Hijab
got
>> Lynford Melbourne. Our referee
don't blink. Ladies and gentlemen,
>> big leg kick. Bumpstead. Three big leg
kicks. Hijab storms his man.
laying body shots.
>> Hijab needs to create the distance to
land the ground and pound. Bumstead
doing a good job by tying him up.
Hijab's got hijab's got to stay heavy.
Move to mount position.
>> Bumstead needs to push away. Cage walk
up, control his man.
>> Hijab landing some elbows. A very good
start by hijab.
Hijab peppering the body.
>> Hijab needs to explode up and land some
ground and pound.
>> Bob said needs to get up. Cage walk up,
but not give his back.
>> Hab is talking to him
>> Khabib style.
Hijab's got a wrist control on the
opposite side. Bumstead trying to make
his way up.
>> Hijab moving to the top position.
Potential Kamura attempt there by
Bumstead from the bottom.
>> Good reaction by Hijab.
Hijab
>> going to ground and pan. Bumstead needs
to move to
>> otherwise the ref is going to stop the
fight.
>> Big elbows by Muhammad. This could be
the end.
>> And the referee stops.
Muhammad Hijab gets the win via ground
and pound
in his second main event. Now goes 2 and
0 as a professional in MMA.
Wow.
Bumpster still on the floor. Hope he's
okay.
>> I can see Bumpster is quite active off
the floor. really trying to work his way
up. But Hijab with his 6'5, 6'6 frame
was just just too powerful.
>> You can see the damage to the side of
his face.
>> He took quite a few heavy blows. So far,
>> I mean, look, these guys are
>> the moment you've all been waiting for.
We are live with big guys.
>> Our first fights are boxing three by two
minute rounds.
>> First off, The way started off very
comfortably, you know, he looked like he
was in the zone and then,
>> you know, as soon as Jay landed those
leg kicks, it almost like it woke hijab
up.
>> Exactly.
>> And just from the sheer velocity of him
coming forward with forward pressure,
you know, Jay Jay went to the floor.
Okay.
>> Amazing performance.
>> We are live here at the Mercy venue.
First bout is a boxing bout. Three
two-minute rounds between Callum Dil
against Fisel Azizi. And red corner
fighter coming in through first is
Callum D
>> of the IFA gym or if gym.
>> Yeah.
So ladies and gentlemen, this
today my fight partner is Muhammad Uma
BJ Black Belt. Always a pleasure to be
working alongside individuals who have
got technical knowledge. Makes my life a
lot easier and gives you guys a great
grounding and understanding of the
technical aspects of what will be going
on today. Especially in the jiu-jitsu
tournament which we have. It's a
eight-man tournament, winner take all
title fight with £1,000 up for grabs.
How are you feeling, Muhammad?
>> By way of firstand stop, Muhammad Hijab.
>> Mohammad Hijab now 2 and0. Fantastic
performance there by him.
>> 100%. I mean, it's a great venue. I
mean, if you look at the decor and a
worthy runner up chandeliers up there
>> put up a great fight,
>> but unfortunately it just wasn't his
day. And I'm sure Bumstead will be back
at some point,
>> but tonight is all about blue corner. We
have victorious heavyweight fighting Evo
Jim
>> again. Been a fantastic evening about
three rounds.
>> The crowd have been great. It's been a
fantastic venue like always, a Mercy
venue in Coventry. Um, it's been an
absolute pleasure commentating the
fights, especially the first dirty
boxing fight. You know, Yasakhan took
the win against Tom Knight. Our MC Adam
Keani here today calling
>> just raising the money for that live as
they come in. We also have our knockout
referees and the lightweight fight
the lightweight champion. Also Majid for
his opponent Floyd will be refereeing
the Brazilian jiujitsu did step up on a
week and a half not
>> and we have Lynford Melbourne and Mick
Fouls for
tonight
took and not forgetting the eightman
tournament.
Bit of an extended introduction here for
the blue corner fighter Faizi
as he makes his way down to the ring or
the cage
for this 73 kilo
boxing bout.
33 minute round of action.
>> And not easy with a person like
>> I'll tell you what me either. but he's
done a fantastic job and I want to thank
every single one of my coaches and fight
zone London Stuart Austin who couldn't
be here today and Aussie MMA Zer Feras
Zahhabi who's been helping me all of the
people who have been helping me you know
Gracie Academy
I want to thank my mom and dad
alhamdulillah and all the all the people
in my life that have come here
facilitate things for me in this trip.
Isam Wahili and all of them.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Now
I want to say who's
>> Oh, now we're talking.
>> Now we're talking.
>> So let me tell you something.
>> Okay. I've won two
>> fights by finish in this organization.
The first one I was cautious. The second
one, as you saw,
>> I didn't want to be
>> overwhelmed. The third one. I want to
see Paul Gold against fires already with
body shots. He needs to keep his hands
up though like the opponent that we had
today. You're no BJ Black's covering up
fight. You can't punch.
>> I mean,
>> let's fight. You've got a feeling out
stage in the first round. But fis,
but then when I'm done with you, I'll
come back to the MMA and I want to
>> punishing body shots. Down goes Callum
for the countdown the champ. So I need
my championship belt here in the UMA.
That's only right.
>> And I don't care who the opponent is and
have Allah on my side.
>> Sign the contract. Give him the cont.
>> Sign the contract tonight and let's do
it.
>> Standing eight count there by the ref.
>> It's a Muslim day.
>> Fisel smells blood. He's going to go for
the finish by the looks of it. I have to
say
>> big cross cross to the body and down
goes again
>> and the referee's seen enough and that's
the end of the first bout
>> a win there by fire is easy of the gym
you
>> strikes to the body and fouls have seen
enough children
>> and has called the Hulk to the bout
>> it'll be so bad
>> great win there by Fisel
>> what's your opinion on that think I'm
terrorizing you inside the ring that's
what's going to happen
as it was wasn't it I You couldn't even
as soon as he got as soon as the fight
the referee call fight
>> Bisel just came out. He had Callum on
the back foot
>> he you know he wanted to assure his
dominance and make sure that he was in
control of the fight.
>> Do anything just keep pushing until you
finish the fight.
Show your appreciation for both
fighters, please.
>> That's the first fight over on the
night.
Omar five live here from Coventry at the
Mercia venue.
Their fifth installment. And what a
night of bouts we have. We have boxing,
K1, MMA, dirty boxing, and ultimately an
eightman tournament in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu.
Once again, show your appreciation for
both fighters. Please
>> and your winner by way of stoppage. 1
minute and 30 seconds into round one,
fighting out of EVO Gym, Fel Azi.
>> Great win there by Fisel Azizi of the
Evo Gym.
This first fight of the night.